Mahal I'm coming your way first with a
really big two-parter so brace yourself
because I was reading I was reading a
quote in our press notes about how you
looked at this project like an acting
Master Class both in terms of watching
what they were doing with their
performances but also with How They
Carried themselves on set so can you
give me an example of each a takeaway
you saw from somebody else's performance
but then also something someone else did
that impressed you in terms of how they
set tone onset oh my gosh I mean well
I'm sitting here with Ethan I think like
what what I found to be really like
beautiful and grounding like as a human
person is Ethan found ways to entertain
himself between setups on the day so you
brought your guitar some days and played
which I thought was so wonderful cuz we
do end up spending quite a lot of time
alone or in our trailers or whatever and
I was like I'm just going to like binge
watch TV but this is better making music
and you know I always feel like half of
being an actor is is mood management yes
you know just trying to maintain because
all of us can behave any way many
different ways every one of us can be
just depends on what mood you're in
exactly and you kind of have to find a
mood and or be able to access the mood
that's right for the movie feel like
mood management management is important
to any career path out there yeah true
one more H follow-up question about a
very specific scene it's the shed scene
I'm watching that scene it's exceptional
but I'm busy sitting there thinking what
is it like one being yelled at by Julia
Roberts but then also what is it like
yelling back because when you say stop
yelling at me it cuts through and I just
can't imagine doing that to an icon
thank you well the beautiful thing about
working with Julia um and Ethan and
Mersa um is that as soon as the cameras
are up we are there with each other you
know what I mean like I never felt like
Junior IED or p poned or anything like
they were like yes we are peers and
we're working together as soon as they
call Action like we're in the world
together so you do what you must do um
but to answer your question uh if
there's any other like actors out there
who are watching this yelling at Julia
Roberts is like the best feeling ever
like not Julia Roberts but like sparring
you know sparring like that like I live
for those moments especially when
they're earned so like our characters
the relationship throughout the movie
that brought us to that point we were
like waiting for that moment to get all
of that all of those feelings out
together so it was like so I mean
literally they we wrapped that day and
we were like hugging on each other and
saying how fun and special it was that
we got to go there together you made the
most of that moment big time I love that
scene all right Ethan for you now in our
notes you described clay as somebody who
means well and does nothing which is
very accurate and was also making me
wonder what do you think clay thinks his
great strength is at the very beginning
of the film and then does it change at
the end of the film does he find a new
source of strength within himself uh
great question I think he would say at
the beginning that he Prides himself on
being affable it's something he's really
proud of that he can get along with
anybody and that he tries to make the
best of every
situation
and the by the end of the film he's
slowly realizing that he's a polyana
and that if you don't have a spine if
you don't offend anyone you perhaps
don't stand for anything and um and
that's a very tough realization that
perhaps by the end of the film he's at
least slightly aware of I don't know I
don't know if he grew a spine but but
he's aware that he doesn't have one
which is a start very satisfying ending
to this movie but I can't help but want
more and know what the next chapter
holds for these characters before they
kick me out of here one silly Disaster
Movie question for you both let's say
real world there is a blackout like in
this movie you can team up with one
Leave the World Behind co-star who do
you pick that you think will give you
the best chance of surviving the
situation oh my gosh not to offend
anyone else but like probably you oh
thank you probably you CU I feel like
you'd be resourceful and think about
stuff we would have the best time we
would have a good
time I don't know you know the you know
you have to there has to be a point to
survival I always think this like the
point is not just to live the point is
to have a good time and to actually live
for something right and um I I would
certainly make sure that we had a good
time I don't know how long we'd live but
the time we had we would do well we
would have fun um but and I think you
and I would have fun together yeah yeah
that's a beautiful answer now I'm
completely rethinking all the people in
my life that I'm like you were probably
the right partner maybe it was someone
else now
I'm obsessed I'm obsessed with your
movie I'm just obsess as obsessed with
this movie as the book congratulations
it is an exceptional adaptation thank
you thank you appreciate it thanks for
your
time